technology is the production is the uh
we could think of it as the residue of
the workings of the imagination
and the imagination is not is under the
control of the
the superego or the over mind so that i
think technology has a weird way
of always escaping the intentions
of those who are working with it a
perfect example
would be the the chip which makes
possible the personal computer
that thing was developed under contract
to the air force by i think sperry rand
and when it was finally finished
it didn't work right it was far too slow
they wanted it for guidance systems of
missiles and this kind of thing
said this thing is a thousand times too
slow it's just
baloney it's worthless toss it in the
waste basket
but somebody said but wait a minute you
know what you could do with this
and created you know an information
revolution that must be absolutely
appalling
to the forces that wish to control i
have an apple ii
computer and a 350 dollar
modem and i can access
the defense department databases
i can access all
the complete shelf list of the library
of congress
all chemical abstracts in short all
information in the world
i can access from my living room in
sonoma county
and so can anyone else who buys a
thousand dollars worth of equipment
this was not part of the plan
this is in fact a terrifying yeah
and my god these computer networks
where as an example a few years ago
someone
invented a device this is an anecdote it
will give you the idea
someone invented a little device which
looked like a ballpoint pen
and it was a small cybernetic device
that could be
programmed with a category
like let's say stamp collector or
saddle masochist and when you wore
this pen if you got near anyone else who
was wearing a similar device
programmed with the same word your pen
would begin flashing a little light the
notion was
that these things could be sold to
people who hang out in singles
bars and would create a dimension
neither public nor private a
new dimension where people of
similar interests could get together
completely so isn't that interesting and
this thing had a range
of 20 feet okay
so now comes the thousand dollars worth
of cybernetic equipment and the
telephone
and it's the same device it doesn't clip
into your shirt pocket
but we've extended the range to include
the entire planet well you can have a
search program on it too oh you do you
go into these
you go into these computer networks and
you
say you know who listed who listed that
they were interested in
mushrooms psychedelics psilocybin
consciousness altering drugs
hallucinogens
and then out of 70 000 users on the
network
in four and a half seconds it tells you
that 12
people listed one or some of those words
you immediately type a little letter to
each one
shoot it off through the system and
you're in contact with those people
this makes conspiracy
on a level almost impossible to conceive
a form of liberation and
these kinds of hard-wired technologies
are simply patriarchal um
follow-ons to the feminizing of
consciousness that is happening in drugs
in other words the you can almost think
of
drugs as the software and cybernetics as
the hardware of what is being done but
vast areas are being opened up for human
interaction completely unregulated
by any kind of institution and these
will create
new kinds of social realities
right it is a psychedelic
it's a hard-wired psychedelic experience
you are
people think tend to think of computers
as masculine i guess because
the first generation of people who built
them were male
but what they actually are are the
mysterious
mama matrix of information it is
like the unconscious made conscious
the unconscious is ceasing to be
unconscious
all information is rising into this
dimension of accessibility
so that you need not wonder how many
people died of tuberculosis in western
nepal
last year you just key into the
biomedical
index and you find out so
and this seems to me you know the word
psychedelic
has been uh attached to the drug
and confined but many things are
psychedelic anything which expands
adam breaks aids and
and supports consciousness is
psychedelic if we take the word
down to the greek roots so this is
this is very exciting
[Music]
you